[Music]
hi
how's that low light well today's
technically our last day like we have on
monday we have some pickups to do and
some visual effects plates to get but
it's not a full-blown production like
this we had 40 days of production this
day for you so in my heart it's my last
day
fondest memory you know when like the
direction and the scene just click and
you watch magic happen it's been a
couple scenes like that that's been cool
well outside of border battles and
resort towns you may not know a lot
about everyday mexico well today wendy
and i are going to take you to a little
hidden gem called guanajuato we're gonna
check it out the streets and sounds and
something very special just for you come
on let's take a ride
[Music]
oh
[Music]
the numerous streets and alleyways here
were developed because this was a silver
town at one point during spanish
colonial days
this town produced two thirds of the
world's silver two-thirds and it still
produces today so in order to get all
those mines and all the people in
in this very small valley as you can see
that's the other side of it right over
there they had to build the town pretty
much house on top of house it resulted
in these really cool stairways and
alleyways there's even the main streets
in the center of town which go
underneath the entire city
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's that guy today is our our last day
of filming our last full day of filming
and we happen to be shooting one of the
most intense scenes of the last episode
as well so quite a good way to go out
here standing in the middle of this
bright light it's definitely the best
scene i think we've shot so far to be
honest dude it's super intense
yeah favorite
memory
alien booty
when i first got a taste of alien booty
it's an inside joke the enigma that is
alien booty so far one of my the best
memories is just just the experience
everyone here is a pro everyone's super
cool our actors and actresses are
incredibly good and i just it's i've
never had an experience working with
professionals in the film industry on
this level not to say the people we
worked with in the past are not pros by
any means but to be surrounded by this
many at the same time
except this one
alien booty
alien booty lover this guy has been
talking about alien booty for how long
dude i spent 90 million dollars tell
them about the christmas booty to get
some of that krogan booty how many
booties are broken elon musk spent his
entire life searching for some alien
booty
yeah i'm taking the long way around mars
gonna hit up some alien booty before i
get back i'll hear about that alien
booty
that true translucent gray alien booty
[Music]
uh so we came down here today we're at
the museum of mummies
there's some pretty crazy stuff around
here apparently they dug
these mummies out of the earth which is
where you usually find them we're gonna
go check them out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just to make sure that there's no detail
here
and there is
it's so dumb aliens are genderless how
do you know that i don't know i feel
like it's just
the only thing they covered up at
roswell was that
[Laughter]
and cut
they were in focus great work
i would definitely say all the laughs on
set even though we have like long days
everyone's tired we have a lot to shoot
we always found a way as a crew and a
cat
laugh about anything it could be
stupid
but we always laughed i'm gonna miss
everybody for sure but season two
praying
to the youtube gods
thank you and there's a picture
oh i've loved working with all of you
and you work hard and i can't wait to
see this show and thank you for just
treating me with so much respect and i
love you guys and this couldn't have
been a better experience
[Applause]
please
can i see it yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah we gotta get in costume so we can
shoot this
how you doing my friend how you doing
come on are you good we're gonna do our
cameo
we're gonna be punks we're gonna be
punks to see some crazy things happen
you're coming on a very spoiler heavy
day that being said i'm ready to punk
out we're about to get punk
yeah punk out with my alien booty
little trailers you're set up like
clothes are in there no you have your
own little room and the clothes are in
there yeah yeah you guys are good to go
set up like normal actors would be so
this is what it's like
you've made it nico
[ __ ] you guys all right i'm gonna walk
over to seth nico's costume is actually
a little funnier than mine he got the
outlandish like red bandanna like
he looks more like a hair metal kind of
guy he's kicks i know it's pretty cool
huh
feels good
you're making
i can stay up as late as i want mom get
out of get out of my life no rules no
rules ice cream for breakfast rules what
rules
you know what i hate police
you want to smoke a pot of weed right
now or what
build my little pot and let's smoke it
i think we should dirty them up
shouldn't we put some stuff on their
face
i think they should be a little just put
some peanut butter you want some some
milk no no
this is a serious scene totally there's
nothing adrian this is a serious scene
there's sam sam
sam stay in the light you're like it's
hidden behind that door
this is actually my favorite moment yeah
yeah this is amazing they're in the shot
get them apple 802 take one amy common
mark
cut it there
all right so on film sets the last step
of the day is called the martini shot
and on friday nights we have a tradition
of putting out a little neon martini
sign now this is an extra special one
because this is also the last shot of
the shoot all right let's do 135 on b
and tilt up on him
and we'll play with it we might want to
milk it a little more speed it up we'll
just feel it out
alien 802 booty take one
hey mark
and that's a cut
cutting
there's nothing better
[Applause]
that's nico
that's a wrap on lifeline
friend yeah what's up what are we doing
right now
all right so the slimmer guys are
awesome gavin and dan we've worked with
them before on the fallout 4 video go
check that out if you haven't but they
just released a new video today and i
saw the thumbnail and was like
it looks like a thousand mousetraps on a
trampoline
and knowing danny's probably going to
dive headfirst into him i wanna see what
happens you wanna see it before i do
yeah
this took hours we've spent four hours
doing this we had a couple of calamities
they haven't even started yet
oh no
well it's still not as bad as the time
he stuck his tongue on one and you see
it like hit his tongue